SARAH TAVEL: Hey, you
guys, how's it going?
All right, so today,
I'm going to take a stab
at answering a
question that I know
as a VC I think about a lot.
And many of you who
are either already
part of these billion
dollar companies,
are going to start one day, or
on the path to building one--
like, how do you do it?
And then, specifically,
like, look,
how do you build a billion
dollar business is really
freaking hard.
There's no recipe for it.
But what I'm going
to answer, and I
think pretty definitively, is,
how do you maximize a product
that you do have to become
one of these enduring
billion dollar companies?
This is something that we
think about a ton at Greylock.
It's our job to find these
companies very, very early on,
figure out the ones
that have potential
by looking at the product, and
see that they actually have
what it takes to become one
of these multibillion dollar
companies.
So just to speak a little
bit to the track record,
I don't know how many of
you guys know Greylock.
But there are five
companies that
were founded after 2000 are
now worth more than $10 billion
in the public market.
And Greylock has invested
in four out of five of them.
And we're talking like super
early stage, series A, series
B. So this is something that
we really take seriously.
And just to give a few
examples-- so Facebook,
early on, we were investors
when it was just still
a college-only community.
LinkedIn, we invested in
even earlier than Facebook
when it was just a pretty small
community of a little over 1
million members.
And just so you guys
know, this thing
isn't in-- it's
not on my slides.
Airbnb, we invested in the
series A, so super early on,
like before it became the
company that it is today.
And it's also my story.
So when I was at Bessemer,
I was investing early stage,
series A, series B companies
and met the Pinterest team
when it was this small,
5 person company, 13,000
registered users, and just got
so excited about the company
that I ended up joining it.
And was there for
about 3 and 1/2 years
before joining
the Greylock team.
And so got to see the company
go from 30,000 registered users
and like this kernel of
a product to the hundred
and-- it's actually 150
million monthly active users
that it is today.
And what I've come to realize
is that what it comes down to
is understanding how engagement
works in your product.
So we think about engagement
as like users are just
kind of engaging
with our product
and they're just using it.
But what I've come to
realize is that you
can think of users as
basically putting fuel
or energy into your product.
And then the key to becoming
one of these enduring,
billion dollar companies
is to take that fuel
and turn it into
something that actually
powers your company forward.
And what I've come
to realize is--
or the way I think about this
now is basically a hierarchy.
And so what I'm going to do,
through this presentation,
is I'm going to talk you
through this hierarchy and some
of the things that you
guys can be thinking about
if you want to take the
product that you have now
and really push it
to the next level.
And so the first level,
which I'll talk about,
is this idea of
growing engaged users.
So how do you-- we talk
about growth all the time,
but what's the type of growth
that we should be focused on,
and how do we make sure that
we're encouraging that growth?
Then I'll talk about
just retaining users.
And I'll finish
it off by talking
about how to make your
product self-perpetuating,
how to find and create
virtuous loops in your product
that is really what will
propel your company forward.
And I think if you can really
focus on these three levels,
you're going to maximize
your chances of building
one of these companies.
So let's talk about
the first level.
So I'm sure you guys all
hear about growth hacking.
And this has become
like the topic du
jour in Silicon Valley, at
least, which is like, oh,
I need to hire a growth hacker.
How are we going to
increase downloads?
What are we going to do to
increase monthly active users?
And what you end up seeing--
and I see this especially
from the VC seat-- is that
there are a lot of companies
that figure it out.
They grow their downloads.
They grow their
monthly active users.
And then it kind of collapses.
Not all growth is created equal.
And what matters is
not growing downloads.
It's not growing like
the top line metrics.
What matters is growing
people that are completing
what I call the core action.
And so you can think
about the core action
as like the foundational
action in your product.
There should be one.
You should figure out what that
action is, what you ultimately
want your users
to do that creates
a foundation of your
product, and then you
optimize the heck out of it
to really get users to do it.
So for Pinterest, we realize
that pinning was ultimately
the core action, that if we did
discovery right on Pinterest,
if we gave you the right
pins, that you would
save those pins to your boards.
And that creates this incredible
flywheel within the company.
Twitter obviously was tweeting.
YouTube, the very innovation
that they had early on
was figuring out how to make
it super simple to get content
into YouTube, which created
this incredible self-fulfilling
prophecy for them.
And when you think through
what your core action is,
it's really important to
really play through the product
roadmap that it creates.
So I think about Pinterest.
And if we chosen click-throughs
as our core action
or if we had chosen actually
original pinnings, so
going from outside of
Pinterest and pinning things
into Pinterest instead
of repinning things
from within
Pinterest, the company
would look completely
different now.
So you really have to be very
thoughtful and intentional
about choosing your core action.
And if you are growing your
company without growing people
completing the core action,
I can't emphasize this enough
because I know we made this
mistake early on at Pinterest.
It's like empty calories.
You feel good for a
while because you see
this top line metric going up.
But at the end of
the day, you're
left really with nothing.
And so what you
should be tracking
is not the lowest
common denominator.
It's tracking the people
that are actually completing
this core action for you.
And it just optimizes you.
It focuses you on
the right things.
And then ultimately,
the question
you have to ask yourself is,
the core action that I have,
is the motivation
for my users going
to be high enough to do it?
Or is it easy enough to do?
And there's some
function of this--
I don't know if any of
you guys know [INAUDIBLE],
but he talks about this.
This is a BJ Fogg model,
actually, a behavior model,
but I think that there's
something really to it, which
is that you have to motivate
your users to get them
over the trigger if you
want your product to grow
to a large enough user base.
So then let's talk
about the next level.
So let's assume you've got--
like, you guys all here
must have this already, which
is that you've got a growing
base of engaged users.
Now, what ultimately
matters more
than anything is getting
those users to stick.
Because look, I see
this all the time.
There's two imaginary
companies, company A and company
B. Company A, as you can
see, is growing twice as
fast as company B. So
the founders of company A
feel fantastic.
But they've got 80%
monthly retention.
It's not that bad, losing 20%
of their users every month.
Whereas this other company,
company B, is only losing 5%.
And so what happens in
the first six months
is that company A, like if
I invested in a company A,
I'd be like, yeah, killing it.
Made the right call here.
But I'm sure you guys
all know how to do math.
What ends up happening is
that after about 12 months
in this random example that
I give, the lines cross.
Because ultimately,
what happens is
that you're only growing
the number of people
that you're losing every month.
And so you don't want to have
this kind of like the empty--
what's that expression?
The empty bucket or the bucket
with a lot of holes in it?
You guys know what
I'm talking about?
Leaky bucket.
So you don't want to
have the leaky buckets.
So how do you make
sure that you're
part of the company B retention
number, not the company A?
And the way that
I think about that
is with what I call accruing
benefits and mounting loss.
So accruing benefits,
the idea there
is that you want your users
to add data into your product,
either explicitly or implicitly.
And then you want
to recycle that data
back to the user in a way that
creates more value for them.
So like when I'm on Facebook
and I engage with content
on my news feed,
Facebook's taking
all that implicit
and explicit data
and using it to
increasingly personalize
the news feed for me and making
it a more engaging product.
And whether it's like what
I click on or even who
I am as a friend,
Facebook uses all
that to create these
accruing benefits.
And the flipside
is that you should
have a user say, the more I
use the product, the more I
have to lose by
leaving the product,
that you create this
experience where I, as a user,
start to depend on your product.
I'm leaving artifacts of
myself in the products
so it almost becomes an
extension of my identity.
Or it's certainly just something
where I rely on it in some way.
And so to give my
favorite example,
I mean, how many of you are
Evernote users or Pocket--
I'll call out Pocket here also.
How many of you
are Evernote users?
I don't know about you guys.
I'm freaking obsessed
with this product.
Every time there's bad
news about Evernote,
I have this, like,
[GASP] what's going
to happen to this company?
Because I have
everything in Evernote.
It has such accruing benefits
and mounting loss for me
that I just find myself
putting more and more content
into Evernote.
Because now when I
do a search, I just
know that it's
everything for me.
It's just going to
get better and better.
And my LTV is infinite.
And I actually pay
the subscription just
to make sure that it stays
around a little bit longer
because that's like
my greatest fear.
You know, Pinterest too.
So when I was at Pinterest,
I was leading product
for our discovery team.
And the thing that
I obsessed over
was, how do I take the action
that my users are doing
and return that back
to them in a way
that creates both the accruing
benefits and mounting loss?
And what you find is that
ultimately, now on Pinterest--
I hope all of you
are Pinterest users.
If you're not, please
sign up after today.
It'll make me feel like
it's a job well done.
But what you see on
Pinterest is that you've
got both this
mounting loss, which
is that you have your boards.
And it's all your bookmarks.
It's your recipes.
It's your favorite articles.
It's inspiration for
a trip you want to do
or what you want to wear.
And then your home feed becomes
more and more personalized
for you.
Because what we do is when
you pin things to a board,
we use that to personalize
recommendations for you
in your home feed.
So like I just
bought a new home.
Now my home feed is all
about the home decor
that I'm thinking about
for my empty place
with just a bunch of boxes.
And so that's the
idea with Pinterest.
There's a flip side to this.
There are plenty of companies
that don't get through level 2.
So one of the companies that--
I don't know if any of you
guys ever use any of
these anonymity apps,
like Whisper or Secret.
I remember when Secret came
out, it was so much fun.
Everybody was adding
secrets on it.
We were all making
fun of each other.
You were finding out the
Silicon Valley gossip.
But then what
happens is that you
delete the app because you kind
of feel bad about using it.
And then someone says,
like two months later, hey,
did you see that
secret in Secret?
And you're like, shit, OK.
So you download Secret again.
You install it.
And you see the secret that
the person's talking about,
and your product
experience is not
any different at that moment in
time than it was two months ago
or if you had been using
the product for two months
because there's no
concept of identity.
And there's no concept
of accruing benefits
or mounting loss for me.
On the other hand, Twitter
actually has anonymity.
That's what's creating
so many of the problems
that they have
right now, actually,
around trolling
and other things.
But the reason that they
have accruing benefits
and mounting loss is because
they have persistent identity.
You can create a fake
account which accomplishes
some of the part of anonymity.
But because I accrue my
followers and the people
I follow, I have my likes,
I have everything else,
they actually can have
retained users with anonymity
at the same time.
And so let's talk level 3
because this is the hardest
level.
I think if any of you
guys are growth people,
you're probably thinking
about some of the loops here.
And so the idea is you've
got this growing user
base, whether it's growing
through word of mouth,
it's growing
through PR, whatever
is causing you to grow.
And you've built a product
that retains those users.
You've got accruing benefits.
You've got mounting loss.
People feel like the more I use
a product, the better it gets,
the more I have to
lose by leaving it.
And now the question
is just whether you
can create virtuous
loops in the product,
because this is what
really, I think,
takes the company from being
a solid player to being
one of those iconic companies.
The strongest virtuous loop
that I'm sure many of you
guys hear about all the
time is a network effect.
And so at Pinterest, we
discovered our network effect
through our process of
creating the discovery team.
It's just this very
simple idea, which
is that when a user
pins a pin, they either
bring a new website, a new piece
of content, into Pinterest,
or they're actually creating
a new edge in our graph
by putting that
pin on their board.
And what we do then is we
take that data of this user
put this pin on this board.
Here all the other pins that
share a board with that pin.
Therefore, those are
all edges in our graph.
And we use that information to
make the discovery experience
better, which gets more
people to pin and engage
with the product.
And you've got this
wonderful virtuous loop.
And there are other
types of virtuous loops
so that you're
always going to be
searching for in your company.
So growth is a great one.
So actually, one of the things
that our growth team was always
thinking about was people
are completing these actions
already on Pinterest.
And how do we take
advantage of the ripples
that they can create?
So as an example-- I use this
example of sending a pin here.
But I think even
a better example
is that each pin
on Pinterest has
been repinned thousands
of times, if not,
on average, millions of times.
And that means that if I
find a pin that you've-- that
there's a recipe,
like a pancake recipe,
that I discover in search,
I could show the person who
pinned it be like a super
engaged user who's already
getting notifications
all the time.
Or I could show it like
a user who hasn't come
to Pinterest for two weeks.
And if I pin that
pancake recipe,
they get a notification,
whether it's
a push notification or
an email, telling them,
hey, Sarah pinned your pin.
Come see where she pinned it.
Come see the other pancake
recipes that she likes.
So then that's an example
of reengaging the user.
So look, these are
really hard to create.
There are so many
companies that try
to create virtuous loops
and just struggle to.
Unfortunately, Evernote,
my favorite company,
is one of those companies.
So I don't know
if any of you guys
have ever tried to do one
of their shared notebooks.
It just doesn't work.
All the time when I accidentally
press the Chat button,
when really, I want to create
a note, it drives me crazy.
But it's Evernote trying
to create virtuous loops
in their product.
But ultimately, it's really
a single player mode product.
Tinder is another example
that I love to make fun of.
So Tinder, you know,
Tinder actually
has some of those
reengagment loops.
It has some of the growth loops,
which is that if we match,
Tinder sends a notification
to you letting you know, hey,
Sarah swiped left on you.
The problem that
Tinder has-- and this
is what all dating
sites have-- is
that if you match with
someone-- and the reason
I make fun of Tinder is
because we don't actually know
this is what happens on Tinder.
But ideally, you
match with someone.
You have a successful
date with someone.
And that's an off-ramp
from the experience.
That's not actually making
the experience more engaging
or creating a stronger loop.
And so Tinder has to
constantly figure out,
how do we get people
at the top of the loop
to keep them dating?
And so as I said, ultimately,
the strongest fuel
you can have for your
company is your users
doing things in the product,
engaging with it in such a way
that they're making the product
stronger, both for themselves
and for other people
in the product,
and they're also figuring out
how to reengage your users
and grow the product for you.
And so last but not least,
how do you measure this?
How do you know if you're
on the right track?
So we've talked about
these three things,
each of the levels
in the hierarchy.
And so I, as an investor,
but I imagine you
as a product manager, or a GM,
or the CEO of your company,
ultimately wants to see
these three things also,
which is am I growing?
Are users getting more or
less engaged over time?
So the users I bought to the
site one year ago versus now,
what percentage of them are
engaging with the product?
Are we getting better over time?
Are we getting worse?
Are the cohorts growing?
Are we retaining them?
And ultimately, how am I
doing on my marketing spin?
Are we getting people
through the funnel?
And so the thing that I
think is the number one
thing to measure, and
everything else, in my view,
is a waste of time,
is looking at cohorts.
And so you look at cohorts.
Does everybody know
what a cohort is?
OK, good.
I'm getting some nods.
The cohort is just all the
users who joined January 2015.
And you track those-- you've
kind of tagged those people,
and you watch them,
month to month,
just as their own
cohort of users.
And you see how many of them,
every week or every month,
are completing your core action,
and what percentage of them
are actually completing
the core action.
So you're getting a sense
of both how many people are
the absolute value,
how are they retaining,
and whether over time, your
product's getting better
at converting the new people
that sign up into people
that are actually
engaging with the product.
And so what you see
is those three things
that I already talked about.
It's like the distillation
of every other metric
that you could possibly track.
And everybody has a different
way that they like to show it.
If you're an early
stage startup or just
getting started with a new
app, I love line graphs.
I just find it's the easiest
way to look at it at a glance
and really understand what's
happening with the company.
But the bigger you
are, the further
you are in your user
growth and maturity,
the more you end up
going to the left.
And so I think
ultimately, if you're
able to track your
cohorts, you're
able to communicate the
value of what you're doing,
both to an investor, if
you end up coming down
this path eventually
or already have,
or anybody else in your company.
So just to close it out, we
talked about the three things
in the hierarchy.
We talked about what it is,
growing an engaged user, what
you actually look for,
what is an engaged user,
focusing on the core action.
We talked about the importance
of retaining those users,
making sure that you
don't have a leaky bucket,
and then figuring out
ways to make the product
self-perpetuating.
And I think that if you are
able to build your product
to check the box and really
excel on these three levels,
I think you've done everything
you can from a product
perspective to maximize
your chances of becoming
one of these iconic companies.
And so just to close,
again, the biggest thing
I want you guys to take
away is that engagement
is like this energy
that your users are
putting into the product.
And its kind of like the wind
blowing or like the water.
If you don't put the windmill or
the dam, you're just losing it.
This energy is there
in the product,
and you're not taking
advantage of it.
But if you take
advantage of it right,
it becomes just this
fuel for your company.
And that's it for me.
So thanks so much, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]